and um  and so like  well okay all right  you can do it yeah okay okay all right  hold on  let's try to make sure i know where we  are  [Applause]  i'll tell them  [Applause]  [Laughter]  [Applause]  right okay we're both on the same page  yeah yeah yeah okay  do you want to know what i would whisper  to him first  go ahead and whisper it whisper just how  i did it  i don't even remember what story i'm  telling you  come on man  yeah the edible was just like i'm here  and i was like wait  [Applause]  you know what  here's what here's the yeah that's yo  here's how yeah here's how  you know drugs can either drugs can hit  you two ways like it can either be like  you know when you're like i think i feel  i think i feel something coming i think  something's coming on i think i feel  something coming on or it can just go  you know what i mean  [Applause]  it's generally that second one a lot  more  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]